i've had so much to say over the past
two years wanting to set the record
straight about what it was that happened
fyi i'm just gonna say it all and then
if we like don't want
to use any of it we can take it out demi
lovato isn't holding back
in her new docu-series demi lovato
dancing with the devil
she should be dead you don't want the
true story from me
i can't believe y'all are doing this so
you just want to know everything
on wednesday the trailer for the 28 year
old singer's youtube originals
docu-series debuted and let's just say
demi is dropping some bombshells most
notably
this i had three strokes
i had a heart attack my doctors said
that i had
five to ten more minutes this marks the
first time demi has shared details of
her near-fatal overdose from
2018. jimmy's good at making you believe
that she's okay
demi is very good at hiding what she
needs to hide
i crossed a line that i had never
crossed are we talking about heroin are
we doing that
and her personal and musical comeback
i'm ready to get back to doing what i
love which is making music
back in january when demi first
announced the project
a press release revealed that the series
will provide quote
an honest look back at some of the most
trying times in lovato's life
as she unearths her prior traumas and
discovers the importance of her physical
emotional and mental health mental
health is something that we all need to
talk about
also in the trailer the triple threat
gets candid about her sobriety
i don't even know why i'm sober anymore
and we learned that demi shot parts of
the docu-series while she was still
engaged to young and the restless star
max eric
i'm re-birthing i am starting over i'm
engaged
after announcing their engagement in
july demi called things off a few months
later in september at the time of their
split a source told et that demi thought
max wasn't being honest about some
things adding the breakup was for the
best
and while it's not clear from the
trailer if the docu-series will cover
their split
it will feature footage from her 2018
tell me you love me world tour
which was going on at the time of her
overdose
this was the best show you have ever
done it's just only going to get better
from here yeah
anytime that you suppress a part of
yourself
it's going to overflow
[Music]
in a statement obtained by et demi says
two years after facing the darkest point
in her life
she's now ready to share her story with
the world
i'm not living my life for other people
or their headlines or their twitter
comments
bye i've had a lot of lives like my cat
you know i'm on my ninth line demi
lovato dancing with the devil will
premiere march
23rd on demi's youtube channel of course
the series is a follow-up to her 2017
youtube documentary simply complicated
there was one night where i used a bunch
of coke
and i popped a few to the nx bars and i
started to
choke a little bit and my heart started
racing
and i remember thinking oh my god i
might be overdosing right now
at the time demi opened up to e.t about
what she hoped viewers learned from the
film
i want people and viewers to take away i
want them to see my journey i want them
to learn
about my life today rather than thinking
about my life in the past
you know a lot of people have heard my
story i've been very open about it but
a lot of people don't know what my life
is like today and i get to share that
with my fans which is so important to me
[Music]